[Music]
in milk drama news milk submitted by a
channel digression New York City is
considering banning chocolate milk in
public schools what what what's next
why is it cuz they're like on a sugar
high and they're beating each other up
or do they just not like black milk that
was only a white milk only you receive
black milk because what I think colored
no do milk makes you feel terrible
you know I don't like milk I know poopy
what do you mean you love milk when was
the last time you drank milk
I had the fondest memories are you know
what I always drink milk
I like that almond milk what I love
cereal milk I'm a soy boy boy boy you
like the swelling so Belka no it's cuz
I'm always on a diet but if I'm not
almost like hey you better because it
tastes better when I was eating ice
cream are you guys come on go ahead
raw milk unpasteurized mash it's the
best man is it really something about it
it's like sweeter
what kind of like like like titty no I
mean like cow kids is Teddy not good I
don't know I'm still waiting you get to
try it right huge I didn't try it last
time Wow try it the next time
oh my god dude you can try out my you
guys want time I'll bring this energy
got plenty I'll try no trip could be
like milk tasty that's pretty cool
okay anyway so the Department of
Education wants to ban chocolate milk
from public schools in New York City why
they are saying that the kids are
getting too much sugar already why are
they getting it in the milk as well well
they should have they should ban orange
juice cuz there's a lot of [ __ ] sugar
regular milk has sugar to have sugar in
that yes juice in general yeah they do
the ads dad sugar in white milk well
according to this article they're saying
that the toilet milk so it says
according to the city health department
8 ounces of public local public schools
chocolate skim milk has 120 calories 20
grams of sugar 8 grams of H grams of it
are added sugar and then the same amount
of skin white milk is 90 calories and 12
grams of sugar none added mmm there's
still talk around the sugar isn't that
what the lactose is yeah it's yeah
that's a natural sugar I think they
should keep the chocolate milk because I
think if you want kids to drink milk it
has a lot of healthy like fats and
proteins and if they have a hard time
drinking white milk chocolate milk is
what's gonna give them a drinking in the
first place a lot of parents and
children kids are voicing their opinions
strawberry milk you could just add
chocolate powder who like that like the
quick yeah oh it's on it's the Chuckle
me I love me toes my chair
alright that Ovaltine son Ovaltine
Ovaltine queens never had it
we need chuckle means I remember those
commercials though those syrup is funny
yeah why they call all the teens the
worst name it sounds like a vitamin er
right did you ever have Horlicks
no that sounds weird - but I liked it
huh with Horlicks it's like it's not
really chocolate it's like this cream
it's like a creamy kind of nutty we play
circle Chinese cafe
that's what you just said to be out like
what champurrado champurrado don't they
have that at King taco warm right yeah
aqua do you look I don't know Minh the
cinnamon in it
the some in a minute sermon note about
the white one the white color one like
the light colored one and they make it
with almond I totally yes no chocolate
milk huh chocolate milk it's being
banned and people are like are you
[ __ ] kidding me just let kids be kids
like just like what part I was saying
like this is probably the only way there
get any calcium or banned soda if you
have to but keep the milk in there oh
man oh man they even have a calorie they
need to have calorie dense things
because there's kids that don't eat at
home yeah that's what they don't [ __ ]
tell you
yeah but the tail should not wag the dog
as they say hmm who says this white
people there's even no white people
movie called wag the dog which is well
the dick shouldn't leave the man but it
does anyway hmm
the null shouldn't [ __ ] be in front
of the face but it was it with him yeah
he was like these idiots man I got a
teleport at but yeah so they're saying
that in LA
they eliminated chocolate milk in 2011
they did yes they did and obesity rates
are the same they brought it back in
2017 after finding that kids really
drifting milk altogether see why they
trying to see any healthy [ __ ] this was
in LA or like what I just said was in LA
and they're trying to ban a New York but
people are like you see it doesn't
[ __ ] work why are you doing it I need
some cheese I need some chips I need
some pizza he's a bucked up [ __ ] mm-hmm
listen [ __ ] eat it eat that [ __ ]
while you can man because when you get
older duty pay for it bro I can't have
talking about knopf like [ __ ] all day
yeah it's like [ __ ] yeah are you lactose
now I don't know maybe something some
some what yeah people develop that as
they get older though yeah I never drink
milk ever I can't lose it
I like the almond milk a lot like the
vanilla almond scoop [ __ ] I can't do it
cuz it looks like milk but then it's
thick and I'm just like why did that you
don't like um it needs to be really
ice-cold and I just don't like that it's
thicker have y'all had goat milk
you ever had cat milk like the weirdest
milk plotz's in their milk cut yeah you
can even cats drink cow milk okay cuz we
feed it feed better no they're actually
like to us intolerant
they are cats milk don't give it to him
oh [ __ ] bring it on cast yeah good thing
you don't feed him cereal okay whatever
feed my cats milk them no don't because
um there was this lecture a cat that I
was trying to nurture and this apartment
that there's the only apartment that I
live on myself with Isaac so this cat
would come all the time so I really like
a bowl of milk outside and so I'd see
him drink like the first time so I'm
like oh cute he's getting nutrition did
he die of it and then like he just
stopped coming so I'm like oh no -
something happened - I don't know should
have put out the chocolate milk oh
that's what it was they're like [ __ ]
this cheap-ass [ __ ] like I never saw
the cat again so I don't know if it
ended up judgmental as I'm going to that
oh grandma
she's always got the chocolate milk it's
talking about more expensive than wow I
don't know just making it up it sounds
like it would be done in a sense or some
[ __ ] I don't know I can't relate to this
milk talk I've never drank it growing up
not you're gonna be a father though you
guys are talking about this stuff a lot
like raising your kids and and like
controversies around [ __ ] like this I
mean how much is getting the same [ __ ] I
had I enjoyed chocolate milk I thought
it was great I came out alright
good for you yeah I think if I was at a
school like that if I had kids at the
school I'll be like oh [ __ ] and pull
them out this is this is gonna raise my
kids and - no but in the whole city
ah the whole city of New York
no find the CD with the biggest obesity
rates and I will move there yep bought
pie Texas boy Texas City yeah I go there
yeah they're saying that there's other
school districts from San Francisco to
Washington DC that have banned flavored
milk canary we burned over dairy has
come up
it's probably like [ __ ] salad for
lunch kind of kids yeah dude oh my god
wait is it about like the dairy is it
about like just the highest sugars cuz I
feel like kids just have so much sugar a
day already there's a bad sugar period
what yeah they should why why banned
sugar huh why ban sugar because sugar is
actually like a drug and they need yeah
then you regulate it sugars and
everything and they don't tell you this
[ __ ] you've already that's why
everyone's got the diabetes man they put
sugar in the fruit it's a conspiracy I
don't have diabetes
my dad has diabetes and he gave me fruit
yep were you gonna that [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
what does he do he barely eats anything
yellow dances you take oatmeal and [ __ ]
Oh mom oh my husband but with fruits but
with fruit he's boring old me brown
sugar yeah yeah he can't do anything fun
yeah or milk nope not really no yeah no
soda nothing do I would start as a kid
you would starve you just eating salads
and [ __ ] mm-hmm I don't know man I I
still give take a healthy amount of
sugar healthy amount of sugar what's a
healthy amount just whatever the [ __ ]
like the milk whatever that is or just
like he'll have a pastry or whatever you
are you balance the mountain before the
no no chocolate milk and just yeah why
not no I'm for whatever cuz he's such a
picky picky eater
I'm not [ __ ] just whatever you want
to put in your mouth go ahead ma'am I
would actually add sugar to my cousin's
bottles of milk what thought yeah why
cuz she's like it's gonna taste bomb
this way because then he'll drink it Oh
cuz he wouldn't drink it regular no oh
oh I don't know how she even came up
with that but I remember seeing her put
like two tablespoons in the bottle is
that white chocolate it's just sugar
yeah sure and cream this is probably how
people talked about smoking in schools
they're like we should not let kids
smoke at school like like 50 years ago
they're like yeah yeah it's cool we all
smoke yeah and then people and then
pants like what the [ __ ] kids smoke
Jesus Christ
we're gonna get that smoke from
infection yeah yeah it was a smoking
like smoke in [ __ ] at hospitals yeah
would promote smoking yes so to say
we're the [ __ ] we're those [ __ ]
right now we're like I'll let my kid eat
the sugar I don't give a [ __ ] like we're
the same people 50 years from now we'll
be seen as barbarians I saw a
documentary about sugar it freaked me
out and then I quit sugar for a month I
read everything I read all the and and
it was [ __ ] crazy they even have the
fake sugar right yeah you got it was
like dextrose mouth or whatever like you
know that it just it doesn't say sugar
you got to read it but it's basic I just
ain't like shabu all the time with no
sauces and then what happened after a
month well for the first week I had the
craziest [ __ ] headache and it was the
worst withdrawal ever
well like I no drug no [ __ ] caffeine
no other nothing made me withdraw like
this it was nuts and then yeah it was
kind of weird but then I lost the most
weight and I couldn't hang because
everything has sugar so then like I just
went back to eating normal but I tried
it and it was it was really weird
that's not thing about paleo for people
I think because there's no sugar in it
right period I uh there's no added sugar
but if you eat fruits and stuff there's
still sugar much it's much lower like
the sugar that occurs and fruits are are
naturally occuring are way lower than
stuff that's put into it and the fruit
like the fiber and the fruit helps you
break down it's slow so the insulin
spikes don't happen hmm so if you eat
fruit like even though you're getting
the sugar you're not getting that
[ __ ] rush
[Music]
[Music]